I read the letter oh my gosh I think I
started screaming as soon as I read the
word congratulations
I just stopped reading my mom was with
me and we were both cheering it was just
like a dream come true for me personally
I wanted to study business but with a
more technological edge I'm learning
industry level skills that's a head
start that's an advantage
my parents were with me on move-in day I
still miss him every day
and my brother can't forget you okay
they got to see where I was going and
they could have faith and I was in a
good place orientation we've definitely
helped a lot don't be afraid to explore
ask questions just meet as many people
as you can
my best friends were from orientation
week I had to tell myself to soak it all
in just embrace the awkward my best
advice to you is go to an event as soon
as you find one work hard but also play
hard if you want to try something new go
for it that doesn't work out then you
know try for something else there's so
many possibilities build hackathon
fraternities and sororities lap singers
even the ballroom dance team if you're
interested we service is a way for me to
take a step back you look at what's
going around me not just that myself
what I really get my memories from are
these extracurriculars and the friends
that I've made you're among the
brightest equals we're all driven and
we're also passionate there's just
really a sense of cooperativeness there
are always people around going to
support you the faculty have always been
there for me I can go to them after
class and just talk to them not even
just about class but about life that's
the culture it's email
I'm an advocate I'm an entrepreneur I'm
a codebreaker because I break all my
code if you're afraid of making mistakes
don't be all of my successes come after
failures how you pick yourself up is
what's really important seeing you has
made me a different person when I walk
across campus I feel like I'm at home
there's a lot of space here for
creativity for excitement
people are building creating anything is
possible
don't be afraid to diverge from your
path whatever you do just give your all
and no matter what the outcome might be
my heart isn't the work my heart is in
the work my heart is in the work